friday there's golf
you probably didn't know this i forgot
all about it and then paulie goes
hey barclay is uh going to be playing
golf on friday and i go
so he goes no he's playing with phil and
steph
and peyton manning and it's tv and i
went well let's get charles on
charles joins us now where are you right
now
i'm in arizona my brother i'm uh getting
ready to head out for a practice round
with the great phil mickelson
okay so it's you and phil against peyton
and steph
yes okay and uh the stakes
now there are side bets on this there's
a lot of side bets but we've already
raised
a lot of money but we all picked a
historically black college
uh and we've already i think they told
me they've already raised six million
dollars we're gonna have to raise a lot
of money for historically black colleges
okay
tnt will broadcast the event it starts
at three eastern
on friday how's your game by the way
i feel very good about my game i'm not
gonna lie dan
and i'll tell you the truth if i don't
play great uh well if i don't play well
i'll be devastated because i've i've
been practicing from four or five hours
every day i feel really good uh i can't
wait
and uh i'll i told you i'll be totally
devastated if i don't play good
okay but what is good and i tell people
this that i played with you
and i think it might have been one of
the best rounds one of the last times
you had a really good round
and this was in a a professional event
you know that was a celebrity event and
you shot a 79
in dayton ohio and people go and what
did he end up with like you shot 79
through 15 holes or something i said no
charles shot 79
that day what are you shooting now
well i haven't been worried about my
score i'm worried about hitting good
shots okay
because you know clearly i got uh
mentally paralyzed
on the golf course from taking two
minute lessons
and thinking too much and choking on the
pressure
i've tried to dial it back and don't
worry about my score
just keep hitting good shots accept the
bad shots
and try to concentrate harder on hitting
more good shots
so i have to be honest with you i
haven't kept score in a year
but i'm just trying to hit a bunch of
good shots
but you talk about this you got in your
head
and you took all these lessons and
if if i put you on the first tee you
were different than you would be on the
practice range
right your swing was different on the
practice range as opposed to when you
actually went to the first tee
well dan you know it's it's really
interesting you phrase it like that
because i've actually played with
players who were great in practice
and once the crowds got in they they
froze up mentally
and that had never happened to me before
because when i played basketball
i went to a whole nother gear when the
crowd was there
that took you to a whole another level
but for some reason
when i got on the golf course uh i just
choked like a dog under pressure plain
and simple
i think now i feel a lot better i i got
a lot
more simplistic uh approach to playing
golf
and still like i say when i was breaking
80 i was always going to shoot between
78 and 84
always and i made the mistake of taking
lessons from efforts i took lessons from
the best teachers in the world
best teachers in the world and i and
sometimes when i go to the
first tee box i hear all 10 of them
talking to me at the same time
you know and i do i i've heard all ted
i've heard hank
i've heard butch uh you know i've had a
bunch of local guys working with me
and now when i step on the first tee i
think about the coach i'm working with
stan
ugly right now i said hey forget
everything you've heard
just remember what stan told you and
just make a good swing
who's going to talk to the most trash on
friday
uh peyton manning uh peyton is amazing
uh him and steph have been killing me uh
which
first of all i deserve it uh but we're
gonna have a lot of fun man
we're gonna raise a lot of money but
like i say i think i'm gonna play well
i'm going to play well will you ask for
advice from mickelson
of course especially on the putting
green uh
you know and also you know when you when
i'm watching when i'm watching
television
you hear guys say you can't miss it
there
and an obviously plan would feel i said
i'm going to ask him
where can i not miss the shot and i
think that's really really important
when i
and there's no person watch the golf
channel more than me
you know i told a friend of mine one
time they could put a guy on tv
and not show me his name and i'm not
talking about dustin or justin thomas
or brooks capricorn or brush december i
think you can put a top
between 20 and 40 in the world don't put
their name up there
and i could tell you who was swinging
the club that's how much i enjoy the
game
steph curry is pretty good like he's oh
he's really he's really good
he's around scratch i'm guessing yeah
he's around scratch and i don't know
what peyton's handicap is but it's an
alternate
alternate shot format so clearly
all the pressure i know i'm the wild
card will be a good way to explain it
you know phil's gonna hit great shots
all the pressure is gonna be on me
and peyton to be honest with you because
i know staff is going to play great i
know phil is going to play great
but when you're in an alternate shot
format like
i do i'm the guy who's got under the
most pressure he's charles barkley the
hall of famer tnt
inside the nba analyst and the event
will take place at stone canyon golf
club that'll be friday
at 3 eastern and this will benefit
historically black colleges and
universities steph
curry is going to be in there with
peyton manning phil mickelson of course
charles barkley are you following the
nba off-season
yeah of course i am it's uh it's been
interesting
um i think the lakers got better
uh clearly i tell you the team i really
like they did the portland trailblazers
uh i think they made a couple nice
additions they got to get everybody
healthy now
you know they didn't have rodney hood
last year and one of my favorite players
zach collins i think going to be a stud
i love the addition of anna's counter i
never understand why people trade in his
counter he's one of my favorite players
in the league
and they say you know i remember it was
this idiot in the nba told me a few
years ago one of my favorite
players is tyson chandler and i'm
talking this is a you know that's one of
you these guys who don't know anything
about basketball you know
they call it analytics they just want to
hire their their their
son-in-law that's what they did all
these owners want to hire their
son-in-law
who made their pretty daughters these
guys don't know anything about
basketball
they're like yeah let's just shoot
threes they go in we win
and we make them we lose this guy said
to me well i don't like tyson chandler
i'm like why they're like oh he does
play defense and rebounding i said you
know those are like the two most
important parts of the game
i mean tyson chandler's been a great
player for a long time one of my
favorite people but
and it's kind of like he doesn't play
defense but i said tell you what
he can score and rebound like a mother
and you give me a guy who can score a
rebound like that he can play on my team
anytime
yeah and you know i love what the lakers
did i i think they got better and it was
interesting that the nba just sort of
i don't i don't know if they realize
what the lakers were doing
when the lakers were doing it but you
know you pick up
schroeder matthews like they they got
younger and it just feels like lebron is
loaded and ready to go for another
championship
yeah i think alex listen uh schroeder
uh is is a good young he's a great
backup
i think when he ran into trouble when he
was starting in atlanta but you saw in
oklahoma city
he's a great back up uh again montrez
harold
coming off the bench gasol to me is a
really good pick up
uh don't forget wes matthews
so but listen all that stuff is
irrelevant you got lebron and they did
you can as you see you can get five guys
off the street
and they got guys who can really play
but like i say
i still like uh what the trailblazers
did
i like what the sixers did uh i like
what my phoenix sons did
uh but listen the lakers are gonna be
the clear front runner
for for the championship explain to me
james harden he didn't want to play with
chris paul anymore
shipped him to oklahoma city he wants to
play with russell westbrook
now he doesn't want to stay in houston
he wants to he turned down 50 million a
year
and now he wants out of houston they did
all of this for james harden
and now he doesn't want to stay there so
what do you do with james harden if
you're the rockets
well they gotta they got to start over
they did that little silly thing where
they put all them little munchkins out
there i thought it could work
uh it wasn't going to work you know
they're like
dan listen you can't put all those
little guys out there
and think they're going to be successful
because you got james who's like
i've said it and people got mad when i
said it because james harden is probably
the greatest offensive player he's not
michael okobe
but his force offers james harden is the
greatest offensive player
i've ever seen you got russell westbrook
who
if you don't like russell westbrook you
don't know anything about basketball
but they put them out there like idiots
with all those little guys
and they're just gonna try to out shoot
you and it now they're no good
and both of those guys won't out they
don't want to spend the last few years
of their careers
uh as a mill of the road bottom feeder
uh
but let me tell you something you've
heard of that what they call it rubber
necking when you see
a car accident yeah i listen
i want their rights if you know you know
how
they do these following the team during
the season
if the brooklyn nets did james harden i
want the rights
to follow that threesome around all
season that would be so amazing and fun
to watch i think i'm telling you man
because
i i think they gonna have her those two
guys are already gonna have a really
difficult time
in new york they both got thinner skin
and flat stanley
and you add james harden to the mix who
wants the ball all the time
i wanted to deliver developmental rights
to the brooklyn nest with james harden
kyrie irving and kevin durant i just
want to watch that fascinating
experiment
do you think it could work i got zero
chance of working uh zero
you know because listen two of the guys
two of the guys listen man
there's only so many things you can do
on a basketball court
when you're a great player you can win a
game offensively
defensively rebounding or assisting
two of those guys just want to score
and it's not going to work durant
he proved that he can play some defense
with the warriors but the other two guys
are terrific offensive players but
neither one's a great defender
they're not great at passing the ball
and you know
listen one of the two of the other guys
gonna be pissed
but they're just standing around
watching one of those other guys dribble
so i would love to see that experiment
that would actually make um at least
while we wouldn't have to talk about uh
jan is not signing the max extension
which is going to be the number one
story for the next
year i hope he signs with milwaukee
and don't be one of these front running
guys i hope he
battles out like the great michael
jordan did or the great dirk nowitzki
did and not try to join a super team
uh and be like uh just jumping on
somebody's bus
is there drinking going on tomorrow or
friday on the golf course
oh i doubt it uh i i don't know anything
about those three guys i'm probably the
only one who likes to drink
uh but uh so no i'm not going to drink
by myself that's
that that makes you a loser when you're
drinking by yourself
i think peyton could probably get after
it a little bit
you know you know i love you know peyton
i think peyton lost my phone number
well tennessee was ranked in the top 25
he called me like everyday time he was
all excited about the auburn game
and now that now they've lost like four
in a row he lost my number when auburn
beat him down this weekend so
i just got to make sure i give him my
phone number again this weekend because
when tennessee was 2-0 in ranked he was
blowing my phone on top he can't wait
for the auburn game
but they've been quiet for the last
month since they lost four in a row
have fun out there on friday charles and
uh tell phil we said hello thanks for
joining us as always happy thanksgiving
hey man happy thanksgiving to the
everybody listening to the show and
especially you and your guys thank you
buddy and so charles barkley
that'll be coming up friday uh stone
canyon golf club that's
down towards tucson i believe it'll be
steph curry
it'll be phil mickelson it'll be peyton
manning and charles barkley tnt will
broadcast the event beginning
at 3 eastern